10 mutant zombies versus 500 winter
skeletons a wither storm versus the
largest army ever
i need you guys to pick who you think
will win in a fight this
warlord or a thousand zombies i think
warlord a thousand zombies
warlord my big brother server start the
battle
go zombies go first wake up
oh wait he's getting angry oh he's
awoken
oh whoa he's one shotting them
no no no no oh i mean the zombies are
doing some damage the zombies are doing
a lot
yes yes don't let him swing
whoa what was that that was a charge
attack come on come on
jenna i think you got the dove oh my god
it's actually closer than i thought
oh why oh less close
fairs his sword stuck it's so close come
on you got it buddy spare at the zombie
oh my gosh chris and carl just got one
point
chandler has zero 500 wizard skeletons
versus 10 mutant zombies skeletons
i think the zombies skeletons whoever
has the least amount of points at the
end of this video has to film the next
video with a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich smushed on their head
what i'm already losing can you tell me
that server start the battle
you can do it zombies oh god go
forward uh-oh oh we got the incredible
hulk
they got him in the corner oh they
killed one yes the giant horde is
approaching from the counter yes sir
work together boys they're spiking them
downward what the heck
oh my gosh wait what are these skeletons
doing over here
wait we might win no he can still win
come on
yes uh chandler we did it
carl has two points and chandler and
chris have one we have one
giant naga versus 300 pillagers
dibs on the snake the snake oh hello
snake man
i believe in naga i need one of you to
pick the pillagers whoever's last to
stand in these blocks has to switch
winner i'll be upset so win oh dear god
oh no oh he's fast shoot him
what are you doing he's not really doing
much come on pillagers tillage
naga you can do it you're letting me
down oh you're almost halfway come on
come on baby
like are any of them dying yeah like
three yes yes
shoot us oh they're fitting them up he's
only got four chunks nothing no
destroy him show no mercy yeah
naga more like nada
that means chandler and carl now have
two points chris you're in dead last
[Music]
500 i don't know why i'm yelling wither
skeleton
versus 10 mutant skeletons let's go
skeley's
10 million those mutant skeletons are
gonna shoot each other what no one told
me that
server if you will oh my gosh i lost
oh wait one died one died two died two
died
don't hurt each other your friends no
yes keep hurting each other
quick scout oh just sit there and die
they are just standing there oh yeah oh
yeah
oh come on play it back he trickshotted
him oh my gosh
high five chris you are currently in
dead last
thanks for reminding me which is why i'm
gonna let you pick first
and the other two have to go on the
opposite holy cow
chris would you rather have 100 armored
pillagers or a scary
beefy mutant enderman i'm gonna go with
the pillagers yeah
yeah that is we won baby look at these
guys they're dripped
out let's see if chris is an idiot or
not server start the battle
oh yeah teleportation use your bows
crush him
i feel like i might be able to win this
look at him go pillagers you can do this
i feel like the enemy's low on health if
chris loses this he's gonna fall even
further behind what are you doing get
closer
oh he's throwing blocks now oh dude
he just stepped on that pillager come on
guys oh no the blocks
the blocks are bad four more come on
shoot him
shoot him
why did he not shoot him while he was
screaming
the this is scream yes high five
chandler
now chandler has four points carl has
three and chris is even further and less
this behemoth right here is a frost maw
and like normal we have 500 wither
skeletons chris
bottom of the leaderboard couldn't be
doing worse so i'll give you the same
treatment you get a pick
i'm gonna pick the frost and carl you
guys are team skellies
okay fine let the fight begin let's go
skully's wake up frostmouth
whoa he's got a force field they can't
even get him oh gosh
oh gosh where are you going he said let
me hop out whoa
get frozen he's doing a lot of damage
now oh get him in the corner
get him in the corner yes bye buddy
frost bye
i just don't know what's going on
chandler five carl four
chris still one how am i supposed to
know chris do you like peanut butter in
your hair
genuinely don't actually we have 200
evokers
and 10 mutant snowmen i just don't even
know what an evoker is how about you
evoke your brain
and pick the winner it's going to be
mutant snowmen he did it again
what do we voters even do servers start
the battle
it doesn't listen to you oh wait it does
oh my gosh what what is that what are
those
oh my gosh they do have magic oh
my chris i'm just not sure about this
one
where'd they go how was i supposed to
know they could
they're gone i'm so sad
chandler has six carla has five and
chris still has one
1 000 mutant snow zombies or two
mutant creepers can i phone a friend
sure and by friend i mean my wife
we're recording a video i just need you
to tell me left or right
right all right let's go please katie
please have chose right
server battle start what the
holy crap oh
okay this guy's not even attacking
what's he doing
he already died wait why did he die
already wait
oh yeah i won yeah my wife was right you
guys should get
wipes they're right sometimes holy cow
whoa what are these yeah dibs chris
picked the stone golems which means you
guys are stuck with skeletons mr server
start the battle whoa okay never mind
we're done for
oh we're ruined let's go oh
we have reigns stay back
oh my god it's actually possible oh my
god it's gonna happen
i don't wanna talk to anybody you're
probably gonna have a pb j on your head
here's one to eat just remember it's
going on your head one sun chief versus
500 spiders
i'm gonna let them pick this time should
we just go with the sun god i wouldn't
even mind losing look how cool he is
we'll take him everyone hates spiders
use that energy
kill the sun god began what is he doing
does he not move
he's calling lasers from the sun oh he
really is a sun chief
oh my god i don't think he's gonna win
this
he doesn't even move go spiders you can
do it go my pretties
oh what he's evolving that was beautiful
his aura is unmatched
he can just use that twice in a row yeah
sun teeth you don't just use your
ultimate two times in a row
and now it's time for the grand finale
a wither storm versus the largest army
ever
drop the nuke he's sucking up blocks
whoa
he's holding a command block so he can
write code what if it banned us
oh laser oh my god
whoa whoa
what is that what the heck he's only
bigger now
all right boys i'll stop there's two of
them jimmy you made it worse
i think you get the point these wilder
bees can destroy a planet i got a slice
of peanut butter and a slice of jelly
and like i said chris has to film the
next video
with this on his head watch the next
video to see what it looks like this is
gonna
suck